I HAVE BILLS TO PAY.
SEAN, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
TIMMY, JOINING US AS THE
EXECUTIVE VP OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION DONALD TRUMP JR.
THERE IS A LOT A LOT TO DECIPHER
HERE.
BUT WHAT I'M BEGINNING TO SEE IS
CORRUPTION, A COMPROMISE,
ADAM SCHIFF A CONGENITAL LIAR,
NOW A NONWHISTLE-BLOWER, WOW.
>> SEAN, IT IS JUST A
CONTINUATION.
WE KNOW THIS IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
IT REALLY STARTED ON
NOVEMBER 9TH 2016.
WHATEVER THEY COULD ADD AND
THERE TO CREATE THE NARRATIVE
AND HONESTLY THE MEDIA IS
HAPPILY WILLING TO SELL IT.
THEY DON'T EVEN PRETEND TO BE
OBJECTIVE ANYMORE.
YOU SAW THAT THIS WEEKEND WHEN
AL-BAGHDADI, THE NUMBER ONE
TARGET ON MY FATHER'S HIT LIST,
THE NUMBER ONE PERSON IN A
CRISIS, THE WORST HUMAN BEING ON
THE FACE OF THIS EARTH IS A
MERE, AUSTERE RELIGIOUS COLOR,
NOT A TERRORIST, NOT A, NOT
SOMEONE WHO THROWS HOMOSEXUALS
OFF OF BUILDINGS, AND AUSTERE,
RELIGIOUS SCHOLAR BUT
NICK SANDMANN ONE OF THE
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM COVINGTON C
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM COVINGTON T
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM COVINGTON O
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM COVINGTON I
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM COVINGTON C
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM COVINGTON A
HOMEGROWN TERRORIST.
THE MEDIA IS DESTROYING THEIR
CREDIBILITY.
THEY ARE TAKING WHAT LITTLE
FAITH PEOPLE HAD LEFT IN THOSE
INSTITUTIONS AND TOTALLY
FLUSHING IT DOWN THE TOILET.
YOU ARE SEEING THAT WITH THE
MEDIA.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT WITH THE
LEFT.
YOU HAVE SEEN THAT WITH
ADAM SCHIFF FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS BECAUSE AGAIN, OTHER THAN
MY FATHER, NO ONE WAS A
BIGGER TARGET OF THE ORIGINAL
RUSSIA HOAX.
NOW YOU HAVE VERSION 2, THEN ME.
AND HE'S ABLE TO ALTER EMAILS.
HE IS ABLE TO LEAK THIS.
HE IS ABLE TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVES.
NOW, YOU HAVE GUYS OUT THERE
SAYING, THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO LET US BE?
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO LET OTHERS
ASK A QUESTION?
I REMEMBER "THE WASHINGTON POST"
MAKING A BIG DEAL ABOUT
DEMOCRACY DYING IN DARKNESS,
YET, THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THIS GOING ON FOR THREE YEARS.
CERTAINLY, NOT FOR THE LAST 40
DAYS OF THIS SHAM AND A DARK
ROOM IN A BASEMENT OF CONGRESS,
IMPEACHMENT INVESTIGATION WHERE
NO ONE IS EVEN ASKING THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON.
IT IS A TRUE DISGRACE, SEAN, BUT
THE GOOD THING IS, IT HAS GONE
SO FAR THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
GET IT.
IT HAS GONE SO FAR, THAT THOSE
PEOPLE COME EVEN THE PEOPLE IN
THE MIDDLE, EVEN THE PEOPLE ON
THE REASONABLE LEFT, WHAT IS LET
OF THEM BECAUSE THIS IS NO
LONGER YOUR GRANDFATHER'S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ANYMORE, THESE
ARE EXTREMIST.
BUT THE REASONABLE PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE, THEY GET IT.
THEY WANT TO SEE THIS PRESIDENT
BE ABLE TO DO HIS JOB.
THEY WANT TO SEE CONGRESS AND
THE ACTUAL LEGISLATION TO
BENEFIT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE USMCA SITTING ON A DESK FOR
NINE MONTHS, NANCY PELOSI
DOESN'T WANT TO DO THAT
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE
TRUMP EVEN A LITTLE BIT OF
CREDIT FOR GETTING THINGS DONE.
THIS PRESIDENT IS GETTING THINGS
DONE FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IN AN UNPRECEDENTED FASHION WITH
UNPRECEDENTED INCOMING FROM THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> Sean: IMAGINE, LOOK AT US
AS A MEDIA TO PROTECT JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN IS ON TAPE WITH QUID
PRO QUO.
EITHER YOU FIRE HIM IN SIX HOURS
OR YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE
BILLION DOLLARS.
QUID PRO QUO.
THEN YOU'VE GOT, DO YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT UKRAINE?
NO.
ANYTHING ABOUT ENERGY?
NO, OIL, GAS KNOW, MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, OH, THAT WAS THE GUY
JOE DEMENTED TO BE FIRED.
IMAGINE IF THAT WASN'T YOUR
NAME, HUNTER BIDEN.
>> I WISH MY NAME WAS HUNTER
BIDEN BECAUSE I COULD GO ABROAD
AND MAKE MILLIONS OFF OF MY
FATHER'S PRESIDENCY.
I WOULD BE A RICH GUY.
IT WOULD BE INCREDIBLE.
BECAUSE MY NAME IS TRUMP COME IF
I TOOK $1.5 MILLION FROM CHINA,
NOT 15 -- $1.05, NOT
$1.5 BILLION, IF I TOOK A
NO-SHOW JOB FOR $83,000 A MONTH
FOR A BUSINESS I KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT IN A LANGUAGE I DIDN'T
SPEAK IN A CORRUPT COUNTRY LIKET
SPEAK IN A CORRUPT COUNTRY LIKEE
UKRAINE WHERE MY DAD SAYS WE
WILL WITHHOLD BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS IF YOU DON'T
GET RID OF THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING ME, THE MEDIA
WOULD END THEMSELVES, SEAN.
THEY WOULD HAVE AN INNERRISM
WITH FAKE NEWS PROBLEMS.
THAT IS THE DOUBLE STANDARD THAT
WE ARE LIVING UNDER RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS THE DOUBLE STANDARD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SICK AND